[Musique]
un jour mon père m'a dit de faire très
attention aux choses qu'on aime le plus
au monde
parce que si on ne fait pas ces mêmes
choses peuvent aussi le détruire la
banque à pleinement saisir tomato
du boulot pour toi a bien payé ce que je
devais faire pour vous je suis prêt à
vous offrir 100 mille euros si vous
refaites nager avec un grand requin
blanc en dehors de la cage j'ai passé 10
ans à les étudier avant de pouvoir
sortir de la cage
vous allez nous montrer comment on doit
mère accepte son nom était facile quand
tu es ce que tu lui affirmé qu'il ferait
une chose que moi même j'étais passé de
pouvoir fait nager avec des requins pour
c'est l'expérience absolue c'est mettre
son courage à l'épreuve non à l'on dit
qu'est ce qu'on va à chaque année la
main très gros x 6 m de long soit très
prudente sur de boulogne alors on va lui
en donner pour son argent c'est parti à
ribéry oscar de la meilleure actrice
olivier martinez
c'est pas bien se passer on retenait
votre toiture
souffle
qu'est ce qui s'passe le problème c'est
qu'au set
[Musique]